so yesterday we had a site family
emergency so we couldn't really finish
the Vlog so good morning day two of the
same Vlog me and Taiko right now
are walking to where
yep to the breakfast spot
um it's not even seven
yeah okay it's 7 10 right now yeah we're
about to cross the road PewDiePie he
dressed himself today so cute come on
hey
so we have made it to our destination
Egg Works I'm with the monkey dude they
gave him a kids menu and all the kids
menu we have Tic-tac-toe and Tech and I
have been playing Tic-Tac-Toe like it's
nobody's business so we're gonna
continue
let's see who's gonna win I got an offer
whoa
let's get all this out of the way
let's play
baby
I go here mama you want me to give me
the answers
you can block me okay let me see block
me because I'm gonna go there
[Applause]
I know that's going that way
blocked you
Colby
um blocked you again
you blocked me
[Applause]
oh my God I made a mistake nobody won no
you won boom boom boom
you won how did they won right here this
line this line
again
[Applause]
so taika has one point oh you got zero
points he beats me and I got zero points
yeah so I put a zero because you know
you got that yeah
and
so taika we played excuse me monkey we
played six games
so Taiko won this one I won this one
nobody won this one nobody won this one
nobody won this one Taiko on this one
making taika the champion
you did I only got one
so we just got home and I
went to just put some a load of dirty
laundry in the washing machine I come
out and this dude right here is doing
the dishes nobody asked him to do it why
are you doing them
foreign
thanks cutie pie
[Music]
to taught you how to do the dishes
nobody
you just know oh okay
I watched you you watch me yeah okay
well don't let me stop you thank you for
helping me
we ended up just spending a lot of
family time together so here is another
day
in the same Vlog but this time tyke and
I are on an adventure where are we going
we're going to California but so if you
guys remember
um a few months back I sold my car
um and since then I haven't had a car
because we were waiting for our escrow
our house loan to clear and close
um because you can't really have two
brand new loans at the same time so that
has closed like literally this week
um but we have to go to California for
an emergency a family emergency
unfortunately
um and I don't have a car so I was like
wait my mom still has some of her stuff
in my garage and before we move out of
this apartment to our new house I can
rent a U-Haul I don't have to fly I
don't have to rent a car
um and I can give her stuff so it was
like the perfect solution so I'm gassing
up right now
it's just me and Tykes on this adventure
I don't think I've ever ridden the
U-Haul truck now so
we are officially on the road got taika
all set up
we are farmers
oh and I can show them what you got from
McDonald's
what's your little thing look like what
did you get
no no this thing right there
I'm so cool
[Music]
stop it I'm not your Tia
I'm showing them oh that's so sweet okay
okay